ya sabemos que es un resorte así que con
un poco de suerte podemos entender cómo
se mueve quiero hacer este vídeo también
para ganar un poco de la intuición de
que es el movimiento armónico y para
entender un poquito qué son las
ecuaciones diferenciales eso lo vamos a
ver cerca del final del vídeo y en el
siguiente vídeo y usa un poco de cálculo
pero no te preocupes si te da mucho
miedo puede destapar te los ojos o
saltarte el vídeo en fin
bueno aquí tenemos un resorte el resorte
es el que está dibujado en blanco y su
estado de reposo es en el cero sin
embargo lo que hicimos fue pegarle una
masa m y estirar el resorte hasta un
punto a va bueno entonces sabemos que
aquí va a empezar a actuar una fuerza
restauradora que está dada por la ley de
hook como sigue esa fuerza es igual a
menos una constante que depende del
resorte multiplicado por la posición en
donde está esta masa de acá bueno esta
fuerza restauradora lo que va a hacer es
empezar a hacer que esta masa se acelere
hacia la izquierda o sea que el resorte
se regrese pues al principio se regresa
un poco lento
pero como hay una aceleración empieza a
aumentar y aumentar la velocidad hasta
que aquí perdimos toda la energía
potencial que teníamos al inicio pero se
convirtió en energía cinética esa
energía cinética hace que la masa se
siga moviendo hasta llegar a este punto
menos a punto en el cual recuperamos
nuestra energía potencial verdad el
resorte se comprime y volvemos a empezar
ahora vamos para allá y de regreso para
allá y de regreso bueno lo que quiero
hacer es agarrar una intuición de cuál
es la posición de la masa en función del
tiempo del tiempo que le vamos a llamar
t eso lo vamos a hacer en este y en los
siguientes vídeos y para esto vamos a
hacer una gráfica déjame tomar este
color amarillo para pintar los ejes lo
voy a pintar para que quede más o menos
a la misma altura entonces ahí tenemos
déjame ponerle un poco más abajo ahí
tenemos la gráfica pero ojo en esta
gráfica nd en este eje en el eje
horizontal vamos a tener el tiempo esa
es nuestra variable independiente y acá
aunque se vea raro vamos a tener la
posición es raro tener el eje x aquí
verticalmente pero así lo estamos
haciendo verdad
está en función del tiempo muy bien
entonces bueno vamos a empezar con un
tiempo facilitó como el tiempo te iguala
0 que pasa al inicio pues al inicio lo
que hicimos fue tomar la masa y ponerla
aquí en el punto a entonces al parecer
el punto a va a ser importante déjame
marcarlo y también parece ser que el
punto menos va a ser importante verdad
porque también vamos a pasar por ahí
entonces este es el punto a y el menos a
y déjame marcar aquí una línea para que
sea un poco más fácil graficar esa línea
no es nada especial da más espacio para
que podamos graficar fácilmente ok
entonces empezando déjame agarrar el
color del resorte que es el blanco
empezando en el tiempo te iguala 0 la
masa está en el punto a entonces estamos
en este punto de por acá y después de
algún tiempo verdad vamos a llegar a
menos a y luego vamos a regresar vamos a
ponerle un nombre a todo este tiempo
total que tardamos en regresar a en
hacer todo esto vale
y ese nombre va a ser el periodo del
resorte déjame marcarlo por algún lado
aquí lo voy a poner le voy a poner t
mayúscula y t mayúscula es el periodo es
lo que se tarda la masa en regresar a su
posición original en dar toda la vuelta
bueno entonces bueno justo como
definimos el periodo así al tiempo te
vamos a tener que la masa también está
en a también está en a pero ahora
podemos decir otras cosas interesantes
por ejemplo entre medios aquí está tema
de medios a la mitad del tiempo donde
estamos que es lo que sucede pues justo
llegamos a la mitad de nuestro camino
que es menos a verdad entonces vamos a
llegar a este punto de acá este punto
también está en la gráfica que nos
interesa y bueno también en esa bueno en
ese paseo pasamos por aquí por el 0
entonces a la mitad de llegar a menos a
llegamos al cero
por aquí y luego cuando vamos de regreso
también pasamos por el 0 entonces este
este punto de acá sería el punto de
cuartos de cuartos y este sería 3 de
cuartos 3
cuartos bueno ya tenemos algunos puntos
sobre la gráfica de la función que nos
interesa pero mi pregunta es podemos
simplemente unirlos así con una línea yo
digo que no sea simplemente unimos con
una línea estos puntos lo que estamos
diciendo es que tiene una pendiente
constante o bien en interpretación
física estamos diciendo que tiene una
velocidad constante pero no es cierto
que la masa tenga una velocidad
constante verdad como platicamos al
principio su velocidad es muy baja de
hecho al mero inicio su velocidad es
cero y luego la aceleración causada por
la fuerza hace que aumente y aumente
aumente hasta llegar acá y luego que
disminuya y disminuya y disminuya hasta
que bueno vayamos al otro lado y así
sucesivamente
entonces no no tiene velocidad constante
esto de aquí no puede ser un zigzag
entonces cómo quedaría pues otra vez
vamos a ver al principio de la velocidad
es muy baja
entonces la pendiente es horizontal pero
luego empezamos a acelerar y acelerar y
acelerar y sobreponer un poco más bonito
acelerar y acelerar y acelera hasta que
llegamos a este punto de aceleración
máxima pero ahora ya pasamos este
la fuerza actúa hacia el otro lado así
que empezamos a desacelerar hasta que
llegamos a menos en donde la velocidad
de 0 y por eso es aquí algo con
pendiente horizontal y en ese momento
ahora empezamos a acelerar hacia el otro
lado mucho mucho mucho mucho hasta que
llegamos acá y misma idea ya ha pasado
este punto ahora aceleramos hacia la
izquierda osea empezamos a tener una
menor velocidad hasta que llegamos acá a
este punto t de hecho podríamos seguirle
verdad misma idea a quienes aceleramos
llegamos acá tocamos este punto etcétera
cuando nada más me voy a preocupar en lo
que sucede en un periodo porque después
nada más se va repitiendo ahora qué
sucede
bueno aquí hay algunos puntos en donde
la velocidad de 0 que son a menos a ok
eso está padre pero pero ahora a qué se
parece esta gráfica o sea no sé tú pero
a mí me parece muchísimo algo que tiene
que ver con trigonometría y de hecho si
tuviera que apostar por alguna función
yo diría que se parece muchísimo a algo
que tiene que ver con cos en sí porque
mira coseno al principio
es 0 seno seno de un ángulo al principio
si es 0 entonces pues no se parece tanto
pero coseno en 0 vale 1 así que si
podemos ajustarlo entonces a mí se me
hace así por pura intuición es todavía
no he probado nada pero a mí se me hace
que la función x x detem x
dt está dada por algo del estilo a jose
no de omega de por qué pues porque justo
en cero coseno de 0 nos queda 1 aquí da
a y pues parece ser que es un coche no y
aquí adentro vamos a tener que hacer
algo para ajustar con respecto al
periodo otra vez no he demostrado nada
después lo vamos a probar algo después
lo vamos a probar y vamos a ver cómo
encontrar este valor de w que me inventé
en términos de cosas que sí sepamos cómo
la masa y tal vez se destaca bueno ahora
sí para poder probar esto y ver qué de
adeveras y se ve así ya tenemos que
meternos con un poquito de cálculo con
un poquito de ecuaciones diferenciales
de hecho a lo mejor es la primera vez
que ves una ecuación diferencial no es
emocional
es un momento como para celebrar bueno
sí más bien te expande este momento otra
vez puedes voltear la vista y no sé ver
el clima o algo así o bien puedes ir a
los vídeos de cálculo para aprender qué
es una derivada y que esto ya no sea tan
intimidante pero bueno el primer paso
que vamos a hacer para reescribir todo
en términos de ecuaciones diferenciales
es reescribir la ley de hook cambiando
la fuerza por masa por aceleración
entonces déjame hacer eso voy a tomar el
color azul entonces lo primero que vamos
a hacer es cambiar esta fuerza y vamos a
poner que masa por aceleración es igual
a menos k x y aquí lo que voy a hacer es
ponerle t
si menos k xt para acordarnos que x está
en función de t otra vez esto es un poco
raro x usualmente es la variable
independiente pero aquí es la variable
dependiente porque depende de ti esto
está bueno porque también nos ayuda un
poco a repasar lo de la parametrización
pero bueno ahora la idea es ver quién es
a cómo podemos poner en términos de x
y para eso vamos a pensar a x a equis dt
o sea estar acá es la gráfica de la
función x dt pero vamos a pensarla como
la posición va entonces la posición es
igual a x x de t bueno entonces la
aceleración bueno para pasar de la
posición a la aceleración primero
necesitamos un punto intermedio que es
la velocidad
entonces la velocidad quien es la
velocidad es como cambiar nuestra
posición en dicho déjame cambiar de
color para que no quede tan monótono
entonces la velocidad la velocidad es
cómo cambia la posición entonces es una
derivada la podemos pensar como x prima
de t hay otras formas de escribirlo la
podemos poner también como la derivada
con respecto a t de x dt o bien como de
x
dt pues nada más para que veas distintas
notaciones y ahora si quién sería la
aceleración la aceleración sería cómo
cambia la velocidad entonces sería la
derivada de la velocidad o bien la
segunda derivada de la posición entonces
finalmente tener
busque la aceleración la aceleración es
igual a la doble derivada
de x con respecto a t o sea de la
posición y para que veas otras
notaciones bueno nada más voy a poner la
equivalente a esta que estas de cuadrada
x / de t cuadrado razón de no a son de
es muy bien entonces ya tenemos todo
expresado en términos de xy de sus
derivadas y en el siguiente vídeo
veremos cómo plantear una ecuación
diferencial y resolverla para ver qué de
adeveras la x se ve de esta forma bueno
nos vemos y hasta la próxima